[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zu salehs welt heute
gibt's ein dessert was sich viele
gewünscht haben weil sie es oft in
meiner story gesehen haben erdbebens das
ist ein dessert aus baiser aus
strawberry es als erdbeeren und creme
also sahne und es ist ein englisches er
ich habe es hier in meinem backbuch
backen für jeden anlass drin und habe es
da ein bisschen verfeinert mit
schokolade warte ich sag's euch wo habe
ich soko lade schokoladen märz 321 nike
immer dazu ist zu sagen weil ich dachte
das wär französisch aber es ist eben
englisch mit frischen erdbeeren und das
ist einfach ein dessert was man als sie
total schmuddelig eigentlich aus aber
wunderschön weil es eine platte ist die
auf dem blech gebacken wird und dann
kommt doch einfach ein bisschen creme
drauf also seine erdbeeren drauf fertig
und es ist wirklich mega mega lecker und
so sieht's im buch aus also und ich habe
mir jetzt überlegt ich zeige euch das
ist ja das grundrezept war wirklich
viele danach gefragt haben
dafür braucht er viel eiweiß eine prise
salz 200 gramm zucker etwas vanille
extrakt und einen teelöffel stärke ja
und das ist hier sozusagen das
grundrezept ihr könnt natürlich wann
exakt austauschen durch tonkabohne zum
beispiel oder ihr könnt noch schokolade
dazu geben im buch habe ich dann einfach
noch zarter schokolade geschmolzen und
mitunter gehoben also da gibt es
wirklich variationsmöglichkeiten ganz
klassisch ist es wirklich nur mit baiser
sahne und erdbeeren heute machen was
aber auch ein bisschen anders verfeinert
als jetzt gebt ihr das eiweiß in die
rührschüssel könnt ihr aufheben und
etwas anderes daraus zubereiten oder
auch einfrieren zum beispiel buchteln
backen oder ein anderes hefegebäck jetzt
kurz steif schlagen eiweiß und salz
die mine fossey
heute wollte ich mal mit der mini
arbeiten
ich bin noch vermieter sieht man das an
meinen augen schon zwar gestern ein
langer tag im shop in mannheim
ich glaube das sieht man ich bin
eingeschlafen vor sanierer und emma ich
hab's ja kommen mit sich bringt
deutschland bringen sich ins bett da bin
ich ins bett eingeschlafen
ja und er lag in runter sagt papa mama
ist in meinem bett eingeschlafen
ok und heute morgen hab ich den wecker
glaube ich hier mal nachgestellt und ich
bin immer noch nie
irgendwann werden sie wacht die augen
perfekt
eiweiß ist schon steif
es gibt ja einfach langsam hier dem
zucker dazu und rührt dann die bg masse
für etwa 18 minuten weiter bis sich der
zucker aufgelöst
oh my god guckt euch diese ww masse an
ich könnte grad löffel wirklich lassen
ok wichtig ist jetzt dass euer offen
vorgeheizt ist auf 190 grad heißluft
wenn ihr keine heißluft habt könnt ihr
auch über unterricht zu nehmen aber das
problem bei ober unterhitze ist einfach
das bbc massa dann dunkel wird also ich
will dass sie trocknet und nicht dass
sie backt wählt dann vielleicht nur 150
grad ober unterhitze und gleich wieder
offen sowieso runter gestellt damit eben
die masse nicht verbrennt aber ich
brauche am anfang kurz
diese große hitze kann ich hier die
stärke kurz dazu 7
das ist übrigens maisstärke sowie
eigentlich zu 90 prozent als alles was
ihr so als speisestärke kauft könnte man
darauf nachlesen ist meist nicht
maisstärke also ist dieses rezept auch
glutenfrei jetzt noch bisschen vanille
extrakt rein und nur kurz unterheben und
masse kommt jetzt hier auf ein blatt
papier
ich nehme jetzt backpapier back folie
geht zwar auch aber dann verlängert sich
die backzeit ein bisschen weil die bank
folie eben das gepäck nicht austrocknen
lässt was er normalerweise ein guter
vorteil ist aber hier möchte ich einfach
dass die bg platte eben auch schon durch
trocknet also die wird nicht komplett
trocken wie normal www von vom bäcker
zum beispiel die es ihnen so marshmallow
artig und außen knusprig also dieses
kriegs schocker augen
sie ist echt der hammer jetzt hier
einfach so ein bisschen verteilen von
einem großen rechteck und ich werde
jetzt gleich die masse noch in vegan zu
bereiten denn das war nicht die ganze
zeit schon ausprobieren was probieren
jetzt einfach zusammen aus
das rechteck ist jetzt etwa 30 x 35 cm
groß jetzt gehe ich direkt an den
backofen und da stelle ich jetzt den
ofen gleich von 190 grad heißluft auf
110 grad herunter das ganze für etwa 40
bis 45 minuten
und wie gesagt wenn ihr mit ober
unterhitze pakt von 150 grad herunter
stellen auf etwa immer sagen 90 grad
und hier habe ich jetzt ein backofen der
hat ne dampf funktion aber das ist kein
volldampf backofen volldampf backofen
ist bei mir hier rechts und dann müsst
ihr auch darauf aufpassen denn in einem
volldampf backofen habt ihr die dichtung
und außen herum und die sind wirklich
komplett dich denn man tut ja komplett
dorf dampf darin das heißt es kommt
keine feuchtigkeit raus also wenn ihr
einen volldampf backofen habt geht ihr
dann her und macht ungefähr zweimal also
so alle 15 minuten ungefähr
den backofen auf lasst kurz die
feuchtigkeit raus dann backofen wieder
zu hier habe ich jetzt nur dampf stoß
backofen das ist okay ich lasse jetzt
aber auch glaube ich einmal zumindest so
die feuchtigkeit raus denn das macht
wirklich ein unterschied und die besemer
city kann dann eben nicht trocknen
also da ein bisschen darauf achten muss
sich auch feststellen als ich mal bisher
gemacht habe im rechten backofen im
verlauf backofen ist die b semester
nicht getrocknet sondern aufgeplatzt 2c
nicht schlimm aber wie gesagt dass er
damals den unterschied kennt und jetzt
machen wir das ganze noch vegan also wir
probieren
für die vegane version braucht im
prinzip die gleichen zutaten außer es
natürlich und stadt bei weiß von hühnern
nehme ich jetzt einfach eiweiß aus
kichererbsen das heißt ich habe jetzt
eine dose kichererbsen und das wasser
was man normalerweise weg schüttet das
sind proteine pur
damit habe ich auch schon mousse au
chocolat hergestellt in veganer version
und dieses wasser ersetzt sozusagen mein
tierisches eiweiß und davon nehme ich
jetzt einfach die gleiche menge
das heißt ich weg das ganz kurz ab ich
rechne immer beweis ungefähr mit 35
gramm bei 4 habe ich also 140 gramm und
aus dem herzen mache ich später ein
humus ich denke dieses kichererbsen
wasser kann man auch ganz gut einfrieren
also wenn ihr mal kichererbsen benutzt
aber gerade keine verwendung habt für
das wasser können das wahrscheinlich
auch super einfrieren und es wird es
hier auch aufgeschäumt schon auch
aufgeschlagen und das funktioniert
tatsächlich richtig gut auch einfach
auch mit salz also hier kurz steif
schlagen und damit er den zucker
dazugeben und genau so verfahren wie
gerade eben
da dachte ich echt so als ich das erste
mal gemacht habe kraft wie das eiweiß
es riecht ein bisschen machten arbeiter
geschmack das verschwindet also schmeckt
echt mega bubis nur mit dem backen aus
das habe ich noch nicht probiert
die könnte man jetzt bedenkenlos in
folge kein rohes ei weiß
also eins muss ich jetzt sagen so allein
vom feeling her fühlt sich an wie ganz
normaler pc machen also wirklich keinen
unterschied ob du das mal probieren okay
so jetzt ist es halt kleine keine
blindverkostung mehr aber probier mal ob
die vegane baiser masse genauso schmeckt
und wird stets herausschmecken das ist
kirche erbsen wasser war oder schmeckt
wie bbc ich etwas aufheben sollen
okay okay dass ich finde auch hier gut
dass mal an ich bin jetzt mal gespannt
ich hoffe dass es sich beim backen
genauso verhält
ich bin gespannt
[Musik]
guck mal bis sie besiegt hatte schon
bereit
und wenn sie sich vom backpapier
vielleicht ablösen lässt ist sie fertig
also das ist so die probe ob sie fertige
solle nicht ich ziehe jetzt hier direkt
auf ein abkühlen gitter
so kann sie gut abkühlen es
wahrscheinlich heißt und dann gucken wir
gleich noch nach der veganen platte
diverse platte sieht wunderbar aus sie
ist perfekt abgekühlt die veganer ist
noch im backofen debug etwas länger als
diese hier also ich guck mal ob sie gut
noch durch trocknet ich habe auch die
temperatur etwas erhöht stoppt die
brauchen einfach mehr hitze
jetzt kann ich hier meinen dass er
fertig stellen zur fertigstellung
nämlich also noch 250 gramm magerquark
200 g schlagsahne etwas vanille extrakt
250 gramm erdbeeren jeweils 150 gramm
blaubeeren und himbeeren und etwas weiße
schokolade also das kann kurz zur seite
und ich sehe er ihr seht ich brauche sie
auch keinen zucker
denn die platte ist jetzt süß genug und
deswegen muss jetzt die sahne creme
sahnequark grimm bei uns das so gut
schmeckt eben nicht so ganz das gleiche
zu nehmen perfekt aus ich probiere ich
glaube es raus ich probiere es nicht
nein nein nein nein
wenn man vielleicht eine größere
schlüssel nehmen und hier kommt jetzt
geschmacklich nur etwas vanille extract
dazu im winter könnt ihr das dass er
auch zum beispiel mit zimt verfeinern
und er so winterliches obst nehmen
bratapfel zum beispiel bestimmt auch
mega lecker jetzt hier kurz steif
schlagen muss es auch keine feste
konsistenz sein kommt die creme hier
direkt drauf
das würde ich jetzt eigentlich dann
wirklich so kurz vorm verzehr machen
also sind auch okay wenn es mal ein
bisschen durchzieht aber jetzt nicht für
nächsten tag vorbereiten die platte
könnte vorbereiten und dann wirklich nur
noch die creme machen die creme ist
jetzt auch nicht ganz stark wie ihr seht
kommt so ein bisschen weicher das ist
auch völlig okay ich habe auch extra
kein seiner partner zu oder sahne steif
damit es eben schön weich bleibt ein
bisschen verteilen und dann ergänzt sich
einfach diese wiese mache dies ist die
cremige konsistenz
die vom doping die früchte noch drauf
perfekt und da werde ich gleich bei der
veganen variante einfach veganer same
nehmen schmeckt mir persönlich zwar
nicht so gut vielleicht liegt es an der
marke ich weiß es nicht aber jetzt
einfach so einen bitteren nachgeschmack
aber ich finde sie für eine vegane
alternative echt gut
probieren wir auch gleich die erdbeeren
werden jetzt geviertelt und kommen hier
drauf die übrigen früchte gebe ich so
drauf
[Musik]
das schöne an diesen bisher ist es gibt
kein richtig oder falsch
also einfach die früchte drauf okay doch
es gibt ein falsch achtung und zwar wenn
er kiwis oder zum beispiel ananas nehmt
dann wird's bitter wenn ihr ein
milchprodukt habt also jetzt gerade
sahne oder quark weil da einfach enzyme
drin sind die das ganze dann bitter
schmecken lassen bei der veganen version
wäre das egal aber wie gesagt nur bei
kindern das müsste ein bisschen
aufpassen und ich hole jetzt auch mit
blatter
die kommen hier gleich noch mit drauf
und die schokolade da macht jetzt
einfach rollschuhen mit einem
sparschäler die kommt noch so drauf
[Musik]
immer wenn ich dass das eher mache weil
ich fast weil es einfach so schön ist
das echt so und haben die erdbeeren vom
klaus drauf vom bau waren einfach die
besten erdbeeren fertig und die asfinag
und dann bin ich fertig gedanke war
gleich probieren
also ich find rein optisch sieht man gar
nichts also es sieht wirklich aus wie
eine ganz normale platte ich habe es nur
länger drin lassen müssen damit sie
einfach trocknet da muss man einfach
gucken aber sie löst sich jetzt auch
super ab dass eben west das ist ja auch
im innern also wie bei dem pablo war
einfach so ein bisschen noch feucht und
marshmallow artig von daher passt es
perfekt ich nehme jetzt hier einfach
statt normaler sahne vegane sahne
ich habe ich noch ein bisschen orangen
passte und vanille extrakt für den
geschmack ich mache jetzt einfach
bisschen anderen geschmack erdbeeren
warum werden die sich aus dem thema weil
ich keine frischen hatte und dunkle
schokolade dann nämlich
zartbitterschokolade weil die von natur
aus vegan ist was ich an veganer sahne
sehr mag ist dass sich schneeweiß ist
also die wir jetzt auch steif geschlagen
ihr könntet ihr auch seiner partner zu
nehmen wenn ihr möchtet sondern partys
auch wiegand
aber wie gesagt ich möchte hier eher so
ein bisschen cremiger haben und nicht
standfest
ihr könnt auch den abtrieb eine orange
nehmen oder zitrone
aber ich finde hier passt vanille und
orange ganz gut was man beachten muss
wenn man doch sein apartment dass es da
nicht mehr glutenfreie ist also so die
variante ist frei mit seiner partner
nicht mehr muss man nur wissen
ich nehme ich jetzt ein paar prom bern
gibt sie hier rein so kann ich nämlich
die creme ein bisschen marmorieren wenn
es klappt das sind sie noch zu frauen
okay es ist ja noch zugefroren egal dann
ohne memory-effekt die flucht so wir
sind anders merkte dass rasches comeback
j ich finde so krass eigentlich sabc
schon weiß aber das ist einfach so weiß
hoch drei dann kam ich krieg noch einmal
effekt hin
[Musik]
egal ich habe es überall sah man mir
nicht über die eltern wirklich jetzt
noch bei manchen lässt sich jetzt sogar
das grün nicht weil es die vegane
version ist sondern einfach alles
schönes
schwarze schokolade hat und welche rolle
hatte ich habe jetzt quatsch zu machen
okay ich konzentriere mich wieder ich
merke seit ein paar tagen beim dreh
mache ich noch mal quatsch viele tage
schon viele tage quatsch ok jetzt nehme
ich hier die zar peter schokolade und
mache mir auch diese rollen
ich kann auch seriös
[Musik]
ok ihr habt euch mein em es gewünscht
hier habt ihr sogar die wie gabel
version und die werden wir gleich
verkosten ein bisschen
[Musik]
also rein optisch findig macht kaum
einen unterschied heute darf philipp
probieren
jetzt fragt ihr euch weiß philipp
philipp hat gerade unseren feigenbaum
gerettet ja denn der feigenbaum der war
leider zu klein in dem kübel jetzt haben
umgesetzt und dann kam der philipp hat
mir im joshua zusammen den bau umgesetzt
was auch philipp heute ist ein glückstag
denn heute gibt es ein dessert mit
baiser ich habe jetzt zwei verschiedene
varianten gemacht dass hier einmal mit
brombeeren und erdbeeren und hiermit so
himbeeren ja und du kannst mal beide
probieren und mir sagen wie die arbeiter
schmecken
okay die zur reihenfolge wie du ich bin
mal gespannt schaut richtig ehrlich sein
also richtig ehrlich viel weg geben
ich habe nichts gesagt darüber ich bin
gespannt auf jeden fall was sehr
sommerlich ist aber das finde ich jetzt
genau auf den sommer richtig cool mit
der erdbeere
allerdings haben wir noch die variante
home werden
ich kann hier auch das stück mit
erdbeere probieren für wissenschaftliche
zwecke ist das jetzt sehr wichtig dass
wir noch den direkten vergleich haben
das muss irgendwie sagen soll ich dieser
pakt mit dem grünen darauf dass grün
kann man übrigens mit essen bei den
erdbeeren drauf gucken wo ist sehr
gesund
ich bin gespannt ich sagte ja auch
gleich was der unterschied war beispiel
ich von dir dann praktisch ehrliches
feedback
dabei wurde das war also auf den ersten
schlag ich mich sagen dass man das ein
bisschen ein bisschen besser schmeckt
das hier
ich bin kein fan von bomben vielleicht
hast du das ding aber das stück mit der
erdbeere auch schon da also wenn da
etwas spielen würde ich das für putzen
auf jeden fall okay jetzt erzähle ich
dir was und dann haut dich von den
socken
ich bin gespannt also das ist nicht ganz
normales pc mit eiweiß und zucker mit
sahne und quark und deswegen aus
kichererbsen wasser
ich habe hier das pc aus kichererbsen
wasser gemacht also statt eiweiß einfach
kichererbsen wasser
ich sehe ich diese genau dieses findet
bei der weg dann hat man so einen
bitteren nachgeschmack so ein bisschen
wenn man es nicht weiß schmeckt man es
vielleicht nicht so gut aus aber ich
finde es einfach das was man mit dieser
kichererbsen mit dem kicker was man
machen kann wirklich gut
wir werden bei uns zwei veganer im haus
und ja wir denken dass das ist so ein
bisschen verstand es ganz genauso
aufschlagen wie eiweiß also hat ihr euch
proteine und dania hat genau ausgesehen
wie bse masse bis beim backen war es ein
bisschen hat es länger gedauert bis es
durch trocknet aber ansonsten sind
gleich halt grad da die blaubeeren drauf
gewesen und die unternehmen werden so
praktisch gleich belegten auch da hätte
ich da gar kein unterschied cool also
philipp vielen dank
vielen dank dass ich möchte jemanden
noch größer würde man gern meine homann
grüßen die um habe ich mir gedacht um
meine freundin gitarrist gibt es neben
gerne alle roma ist redete reza ich
kriege ich auch ganz lieb ist ja also
viel spaß aber nachhaken der klassischen
und der veganen version probiert gern
mal aus gibt mir ein feedback und die
rezepte findet ihr wie immer auch sex -
blog de oder in der app dankeschön darf
natürlich auch aufessen ja sarah es tut
mir leid ich hab dich ausgetauscht es
tut mir so leid aber philipp hat aber
ich dachte so ja ich hab mir gedacht
komm mit mann verkostet hat er einfach
so unvoreingenommen hier probiert und
was ist das weiße schokolade und hier
habe ich zwar bitter weil weiß es nicht
vegan und bitterschokolade ist schon
vegan weil keine voll milch drin ist
also ein muss man echt nett viel
austauschen ich hab eigentlich nur die
hier die sahne ausgetauscht und das
eiweiß zudem klar so ein richtiges
odyssee also bis zum nächsten mal
von sarah will probieren kommen wir
lassen noch sarah die fachfrau die darf
auch noch probieren okay du bist auch
fachmann jetzt kommt die fachfrau jetzt
haben beides fachmann und fachfrau wir
bleiben jetzt alle drei im bild kaum
sarah shop den löffel ich hol dir gleich
dein speise raus kam stelle ich mal
zwischen uns noch mal deinen ton auch
schön so noch mehr so
ja ich muss echt sagen dass veganer das
spiel so besser schneiden machte
unterschied wie lange man dazu bereit
ist heute der backzeit also habe ich 45
minuten gebacken und hier glaubt über
eine stunde sogar lauter reden es ist
schon weich in zehn zentimeter macht es
auch bei dem glaube ich so trainingsplan
da habe ich kein dankeschön
unterschiedlich
ich glaube nur wegen der umwelt aber
krasser da ich die feinschmecker gegen
das natürlich schon aber ich muss schon
sagen wer philipp hat es echt gut macht
kann es öfter vorbei kommen mache ich
zum probieren sehr muss ich dann jedes
mal warum im großen garten also mal
wieder ein unterschied wahnsinnig viele
hause ich bin voll ich bin voll geflasht
bischofskirche ja also wenn ich das
nächste mal die herzen wasser übrig habt
macht einfach bis es raus ich hole jetzt
einspeisen rauskomme ich fertig
[Musik]